[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами пані Ліда і мій друг
ведмежатко бо привіт привіт всім привіт
Ми подорожуємо з вами абеткою і сьогодні
у нас новенька наступна буква вона є
особливою А чим вона особлива Ви
дізнаєтеся тоді коли ми все про неї
розкажемось ведмедику а зараз я пропоную
повторити вже ці літери які ми вже з
вами вивчили ось Подивіться на екран у
вас будуть буквочки і ви Пригадайте як
вони називаються ведмедику допоможе
діткам так так допоможемо а
молодці друзі ви назвали всі літери які
ми вже з вами вивчили А зараз з цими
літерами які ми вже вчили Давайте
спробуємо прочитати деякі склади ось
Подивіться ведмежатко Допоможеш мені так
ось ми поставимо дві літери а ваше
завдання прочитати який склад утворився
ведмежатко Ану спробуйте
бо
вірно Молодчинка гарно А у вас друзі теж
вийшов склад баб думаю що так Гаразд
Давайте змінимо приголосний і утворимо
інший склад Ось і прочитаємо його так
ведмежатко
Правильно молодець бо ти молодчинка а ви
друзі прочитали
Гаразд наступний літера ось спробуйте
прочитати цей склад
за вірно Молодці так рухаємося далі і
візьмемо ще одну літеру яку ми вчили з
вами Ось вона
і склад утворився да
Молодці супер А зараз Ми змінимо ще й
голосний звук і спробуємо прочитати інші
склади поставимо голосний який звучить
як
вірно і до нього додаємо приголосний і
вийшов склад ведмежатко
б вірно змінимо приголосний
і прочитаємо
де вірного молодці і знову змінимо
приголосний Ось на жучка подібний
пам'ятаєте
і у нас утворився склад
ж
молодці друзі отак потихеньку від літери
до літери ми навчимося з вами читати
молодці а зараз з вами ми переходимо до
новенької літери яка називається
їй чим незвична ця літера то тому що
вона означає два звуки й і ось
Подивіться як виглядає літера ї Ось вона
на яку літеру вона вам подібна друзі
Пригадайте ось ви бачите її сестричку
літеру і ведмежатко Ти бачиш як вони
схожі тук-тук вони дуже-дуже схожі
тільки відрізняються двома крапочками
правильно лише відрізняються двома
крапочками і ми зможемо з вами дуже
просто скласти літеру і ї за допомогою
олівця чи фломастера як у мене ось ми
покладемо фломастер так паличка і
замість крапочок У мене є дві фасолинки
ось ми покладемо одну фасолинку і другу
фасолинку і побачимо щось Дуже схоже на
літеру ї а якщо ми гарно придивимося то
подумаємо А на яку цифру схожа літера ї
подумайте друзі
так на цифру один на одиничку вірно
молодці послухайте будь ласка ось є в
мене є віршик про літеру ї ведмежатко
послухаєш тут я дуже все це люблю ось
буква ї дві крапки має це її і вирізняє
якщо крапку нам забрати букву і будемо
мати Хоч вони подібні дуже але букви
різні друже тож її потрібно вчити адже
Як без їжі жити їсти треба щоб рости
краще їхати чи мій ти на цю букву хочеш
знати лиш одну тваринку звати в неї
шубка з колючок її звати
ведмедику Що це за тваринка з колючками
їжачок вірно вірно ведмедику правильно
їжачок Отже ви запам'ятали що
буквочка ї означає два звуки й і але
одну буквочку Гаразд Давайте подумаємо
які ще є слова які починаються з цієї
літери
наприклад Ось у віршику ви почули слово
їжа ще
їжачок добре
їхати їдальня
ї
Україна і в слові Україна теж є літера ї
А ще є дуже гарне слово
Київ Київ друзі це місто столиця нашої
України ти знав про це ведмедику Так я
чув про це я чув Отже Україна Київ Всюди
є літера ї правильна ведмедику А ще є
дуже гарне ім'я дівчинки
Таїсія теж є літера ї ну що ж Давайте ми
з вами спробуємо скласти і з наших літер
слово у якому теж є літера ї і першою
літерою буде
ї ви друзі будьте уважні і Прочитайте
яке слово у нас утвориться
А
ведмедику прочитаємо разом друзі у нас
утворилося слово
їжа їжа а якщо ми до слова їжа додамо ще
літеру К
то у нас утвориться якась тваринка яка
тваринка Давайте спробуємо і прочитаємо
слово
їжак Ось у нас зі слова їжа утворився
їжак їжачок Бачите як це цікаво
добавляючи різні літери ми можемо
перетворювати одні слова в інші А зараз
Давайте порахуємо скільки буквочок у
слові їжак
ведмедику Ти готовий давай порахуємо
один два три чотири чотири літери у
слові їжак і ми знайдемо цифру 4 серед
наших цифр ось цифра 4
буквочки і цифри чотири
вірно молодець друзі А порахуйте скільки
звуків у слові їжа давайте промовимо всі
звуки які ми чуємо її
і
ж а к 5 звуків у слові їжа і 4 літери
давайте віднайдемо цифру 5 ведмедику Ось
вона вірно 5 звуків і 4 букви тому що
пам'ятаєте на початку я вам казала що ця
буквочка особливо вона означає два звуки
й і
р молодці друзі а Зараз ми з ведмедиком
розкажемо вам історію про цю буквочку у
літери
Ось вона я сестричка
[музика]
Як ви вже знаєте літера
ї а пригадайте які ще дві сестрички ми
вже з вами вивчили вони дуже-дуже
подібні а в одної сестрички такі Чубчик
догори зачесаний пам'ятаєте
це дві літери
; г
молодці пам'ятаєте
ось наші дві сестрички і та ї були
зовсім-зовсім однакові тільки у літери ї
Як ви бачите були дві крапочки але вона
Чомусь через свою неуважність постійно
їх втрачала одного разу їй пішла гуляти
у ліс І загубила свої дві крапочки
і так Засмутилось тепер мене ніхто не
впізнає на її плач прийшов їжачок і
сказав Не плач Я тобі допоможу він почав
кататися клубочком і знайшов крапочки та
поверну їх літері ї вона дуже-дуже
зраділа бо без крапочок її сприймали за
буквочку і вона почепила крапочки та
запросила їжачка у їдальню з тих пір
Їжачок та літера ї
потаворушували і завжди допомагали один
одному отака історія ведмедику
ви знаєте що ми знаємо з ведмедиком дуже
багато різних скоромовок про Їжачка і я
пропоную вам їх разом вивчити готові
Нумо починаємо ось послухайте
їжак їжака голками не зляка Адже всі
їжачки мають голочки і вони не лякаються
голочок один одного
Тепер давайте ви спочатку повільно
їжак їжака голками не зляка А тепер
швидше
їжак їжака голками не зляка А тепер ще
швидше їжак їжака голками не зляка ваша
черга
Так у вас гарно виходить і дуже-дуже
швидко їжак їжака голками не злякав
молодці Ми вже вивчили з вами одну
скоромовку А в нас ведмедиком є ще одна
без послухайте їжачок їжаченя їздять по
гриби щодня їжачиха помагає сироїжки їм
збирає що таке сироїжки друзі це такі
грибочки так давайте повільно спочатку
їжачок їжаченя їдять
по гриби щодня
їжачиха помагає сироїжки їм збираю
давайте ще раз повільно будь ласка
їжачок їжаченя їздять по гриби щодня
їжачиха допомагає сироїжки їм збирає
давайте ще швидше запам'ятали
спробуємо
їжачок їжаченя їздять по гриби щодня
їжачиха вимагає із сироїжки їм збирає
спробуємо ще ведмедику ти запам'ятав
давайте про твоя черга
їжачок їжаченю їдять по гриби щодня
їжачиха помагає сирішкін збирає Давай ще
раз зможеш швидше спробую
їжачок їжаченя і від Погреби щодня
їжачих помагає сироїжки їм збирає Ого
Клас молодець в тебе получилося
Сподіваюся друзі у вас теж вийшла така
класна скоромовка про їжачків молодці а
зараз час на гру друзі зараз я буду
називати тваринок
А вам потрібно здогадатись Чим вкриті ці
тваринки адже в кожної тваринки може
бути наверху на тілі щось різне можуть
бути пір'їни тому що у слові пір'їна є
теж літера ї яку ми сьогодні з вами
вивчаємо А може бути хутро
і ви повинні назвати якщо я називаю
тваринку у якої є пір'їна ви кажете
під або пір'їна А якщо хутро ви говорите
хутро домовились Гаразд вдома починати
голуб
пір'їна правильно пір'ячком вкрити голуб
Гаразд далі Ведмідь
утро В нас У ведмедика є хутро тепле
тепле йому не холодно вірно йдемо далі
страус
піріна правильно молодці індик
і знову пір'їна є лисиця
хутро правильно молодці вовк
хутро правильно молодці йдемо далі
синиця
пір'їна пір'їна вірно вірно друзі Лебідь
такий красивий красивий птах з
видовженою шиєю дуже благородний
пір'їна вірно сорока
теж пір'їна молодці а ось вам таке ще
завдання пінгвін чим вкритий пінгвін
хутром чи пір'їнами
Як ви думаєте
вірно і пінгвін теж має пір'їнки
уявляєте пінгвіни це теж птахи Хоч вони
і не літають але вкритий пір'ям пір'я це
просочене жиром і допомагає утримувати
тепло тому пінгвінам і не холодно Хоч
вони живуть на
південному полюсі Гаразд Друзі Ну що ж
ви напевно здогадалися що всі пташки
вкриті пір'їнками і у слові пір'їна Ми
теж чуємо літеру ї і звуки й і молодці
сьогодні ви були теж надзвичайні молодці
вивчили нову літеру ї навчилися
вимовляти скоромовки
і побавилось у різні ігри А нам час
прощатись Друзі на все добре па-па
[музика]
Привіт друзі з вами пані Настя і прийшов
час трошечки порухатись і розрухати своє
тіло Ви готові
приготуйтесь будь ласка станьте в зручне
для вас місце там де ви нічого не можете
зачепити
добре стаємо рівненько
Ось так робимо вдих
і ви
ди спробуємо носиком вдих
і
х чудово розминаємо наші кисті крутимо
їх по колу
так і в іншу сторону
чудово тепер лікті
і в іншу сторону
Добре тепер ручка рівна назад
і вперед
Окей молодці Тепер інша рука назад 3 4 5
6 7 8 і вперед 8 1 порахуйте зі мною 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 чудово трошки струшуємо наші
кисті струшуємо наші плечики Окей
ставимо ручки на пояс і порухаємо нашим
тазом
по колу
і в іншу сторону
рухається так
не плечики а ТАС
чудово Добре тепер піднімаємо коліно
вгору наче крокуємо на місці але дуже
високо піднімаємо ноги
так і ще вище спробуйте Куди ви можете
дістати найвище
Окей Чудово А тепер в сторону в сторону
сторону сторону
так
і ще
Окей молодці тепер потрібно стати
дуже-дуже широко як можете ширше і тепер
ми будемо нахилятися до однієї ніжки і
до іншої потрібно буде доторкнутися до
носочка так
Супер А тепер доторкнулися
навхрест і витягуємо цю ручку Вверх
і поміняли навхрест а іншу вверх
подивилися на неї і ще навхрест інша
верх подивилася на великий пальчик і
поміняли на великий пальчик дивимось і
ще
і помінялися чудово зібрали ніжки і
трошечки з вами пострибаємо зробимо таку
зірочку ми стрибаємо ніжки в сторони і
ручки в нас будуть відкриватися ще раз
ручки в сторону
і ніжки старень і рівненько і ще як
морська зірка і зібралась А тепер
спробуємо зробити це швидше раз два раз
два раз раз два
Окей молодці Чудово Ну а тепер ми будемо
робити вправу на підлозі нам потрібно
ручками стати на підлогу і відійти
ніжками спіймо в такій планці не
провалюєтесь вниз і не піднімайте на
гору ми маємо бути посередині так добре
а тепер ми біжимо на місці спробуйте
побігти
це не просто але я впевнена що у вас
виходить є і зробимо собачку Ви вже
вмієте і підстрибнули до ручок і виросли
вгору Окей робимо вдих
і види
х і ще вдих
і видих і останній раз вдих
і
видих супер Посміхніться собі пограйте
себе по голові Ви молодці зробила дуже
класно руханку була рада вас бачити
па-па
[музика]